those two squares were cut out from a
single sheet of paper printing paper
that I took from my office I put them
together like so and clamp them together
with a binder clip actually when you do
this with friends and family at home you
can use your fingers to support those
two sheets but if I use fingers people
start accusing me of cheating so let's
introduce some objectivity by using an
instrument so there's a binder clip
there and if I hold those squares like
this they stick together of course
you'll say because they are made of the
same material they react the same way
they s the same way under Gravity so
there's no reason why you know they
don't stick together but when I turn
them around they
separate so on one side they stick
together on the other side they separate
but there's more to this this side you
see that they're separating and flipped
over you recall it was the Sticky Side
while keeping the squares on the
separating side let's make the binder
migrate to the next Edge okay it used to
be here now it's gone here and I kept
them on the separate inside but this
time supported on this Edge they stick
together and the other side which used
to be the sticky side now
separates so I didn't do anything
violent like you know chemical treatment
or pooling and so on but that is some
something to them and this whole thing
comes from the interest in anisotropic
materials that is properties of
materials that depend on Direction you
know this direction this Direction
different the modern method of
manufacturing paper pulls the paper out
of a big big roller so it introduces
some sort of graininess in One Direction
which makes maybe the resting paper this
direction this direction not strictly
equivalent now for all practical
purposes this non equivalence is almost
always invisible and IM material but
playing with paper and playing with toys
like this you can make them come out as
follows so let's make it a bit more
clear because I'm very fond of toys this
is a toy but I've brought a a toy of a
toy it's a secondary toy if you like I'm
using another toy to illustrate at the
First toy if you crease paper like this
it's quite flexible in this direction in
this direction it becomes stiff you
can't bend it anymore now that's the
ancient technology of corrugated surface
of course but for mathematically minded
people I might ler the point because I
curved it in this direction already if I
try to curve it in the other direction I
would introduce what is called non-zero
Gan curvature which I can't do without
violence to paper which to begin with
had zero curvature and curvature turns
out to be an invariant that is as long
as you don't tear stretch and so
curvature must be the same so if it's
zero to begin with it's zero always so
the gussian curvature in the nutshell is
acting as a stop to being bent or if you
like you know when we crease a sheet of
paper or any surface one of the useful
reasons for creasing is that when you
crease a sheet or membrane or Surface
like this it becomes more flexible in
this direction but suddenly introduces a
bit of rigidity in this direction so
creasing is a mechanism for introducing
directional rigidity okay let's go back
when I saw this sheet of paper from my
office well I couldn't tell the
microscopic fiber an isotopy and so
forth precisely because it's too small
but I don't have to know anything I just
cut out two squares next to each other
and when I assemble them I put them one
on top of the other like so by rotating
one on top of the other by 90° and in
this toy model you'll see exactly what
happens if I support those two objects
like this they stick together because
the stiff one is at the bottom
supporting the flex one at the top but
when I turn around they can separate
because the flexible one can suck but
stiff one sticks out and when I migrate
to the next Edge the sticky and
non-separating sides swap their rolls
almost certainly this is what is going
on microscopically in in this model when
I first made this on a normal sheet of
paper I simply couldn't see the small SP
scale structures but it doesn't matter I
just cut two squares and rotated one on
top of the other by 90° that's all you
have to do in retrospect book binders
know this because you have to use the
paper in the right direction apparently
if you use it in the wrong direction the
book becomes very difficult to open
whereas if you line it in the correct
direction it becomes very easy book to
use and so people who work with paper
know this of course from experience but
at the same time um you know I'm quite
fond of Japanese calligraphy you might
have seen this is traditional ultimate
comes from China you just use ink and
very sort of Stark sheet of paper and
then you do all sorts of things with
just black ink painting or calligraphy
I'm not so good at this so I can't
really tell the difference but I know
that the great Masters insist on using
paper that is manufactured in the
traditional way that is you start from
some sort of Pulp MH and you let it
sediment without pulling in a direction
and then you compress apparently that's
how you make the paper so that the
little fibers are randomly oriented in
other words it is quite isotropic it's
quite directional independent and when
those mustards draw things like that
well they can go in all directions
freely whereas they say well if you use
the commercial you know modern paper
which has some directionality well you
know this stroke is not compatible with
that stroke and so forth they complain I
mean I as I say I can't tell the
difference but there are people who are
sensitive enough to tell the difference
so there are examples like this too yet
one more example from really daily life
is this I don't know if it's the first
time that toilet paper makes an
appearance in number file if you take a
tissue paper you can try to tear it
straight and in One Direction it's fair
very easy to do so but if you take the
same paper and try to tear it in the
perpendicular Direction I just torn it
in this direction but now I tell it's
basically impossible to go straight you
can't tear
it and that's certainly because of the
anotr of paper there's a difference
between tearing down like this and
tearing across like this I found this
toilet paper from the bathroom of the
mathematical Sciences Research Institute
msri and I was amused to note that this
toilet paper I roller like this is easy
to tear straight in this direction along
the length but across the width it's
impossible to tear straight and I
thought aha that is funny but on second
thoughts I realized that of course it
has to be that way because you see when
you tear toilet paper you want it to be
very difficult to tear except along the
perforations where you deliberately
introduce perforations to it to be
tearable in some units so of course it
should be easy to tear along the length
and across the width you want it to be
difficult to tear so every day I become
a little smarter so you can do this at
home in this direction it's very easy to
tear but in this direction it's it's
almost impossible except along the
perforation where I can I can tear quite
nicely as the paper
should in the same direction that's why
they circulating in the same direction
that I'm swirling because they are not
um talking to one another they
independent
particles in contrast when you increase
the crowdedness well whatever linear
momentum I input into the system